أعلن فلاديمير بوتين للتو أن
روسيا قد
طورت ووافقت على لقاح الفيروس التاجي
سانجاي وهو يؤمن به كثيرًا لدرجة أن ابنته
قد تعاملت معه جيدًا بالفعل ،
كيف يجب أن ننظر إلى هذا
الآن ، هل
ستكون مرتاحًا لأخذ هذا اللقاح هذا
الصباح
لن أكون مرتاحًا تمامًا
لأخذ هذا اللقاح ، فأنا لا أعلم شيئًا
عن هذا اللقاح الذي لم يشاركوه
في أي بيانات وأنت تعلم أنني كنت
أتابع القصة لبعض الوقت
الآن وأنا تعرف وأحاول فهم
ما يحدث في روسيا
نحن نعلم أنهم كانوا يعملون على
هذا اللقاح منذ فترة أه
هو ما يسمى
بلقاح النظام الأساسي
للفيروسات الغدية حيث يأخذون فيروسًا مختلفًا وفيروسًا غديًا بشكل
أساسي ، فأنت تعلم أنه يتبادل
الجينات لهذا اللقاح هذا الفيروس مع هذا
الفيروس التاجي
لذا فهو أقرب  يشبه
فيروس كورونا ، ثم يعطون ذلك
للأشخاص الذين
يحاولون تحفيز استجابة الجسم المضاد ،
إنه مشابه لما
لقاح أسترازينيكا و  لقاح كان سينو
خارج الصين من نفس النوع من
النظام الأساسي ولكن ليس لدينا بيانات حول
هذا ونعلم أيضًا أنك تعلم أنك ذكرت
ابنة فلاديمير بوتين ونعلم أيضًا
أن بعض الباحثين في المختبر
وفقًا لبعض التقارير التي سمعناها
قدموا لأنفسهم اللقاح في وقت مبكر أيضًا كجزء
من المرحلة الأولى من الدراسة التي عادت إلى
مايو
وهو أمر عديم الضمير للغاية ، أعني
أن هذا شيء
لم يتم إجراؤه عادةً ، إنه ليس جزءًا من الدراسة ، إنه
مجرد شيء
يفعله الناس على ما يبدو في هذا المختبر
فقط.  هم أنفسهم هذا اللقاح ،
لكننا لا نعرف أي شيء عن
هذا اللقاح ولم نر أي بيانات
ويجب أن أخبركم بعد أن غطت
الإيبولا على نطاق واسع ، لقد عاد هذا منذ ست سبع
سنوات الآن ،
كان هناك أيضًا الكثير من الحديث عن
لقاح من روسيا في ذلك الوقت  نقطة
للإيبولا
والتي أطلقوا عليها اسم اللقاح الأكثر فاعلية
في العالم
ولم أر أبدًا أي بيانات عن المرحلة 3 حول هذا
اللقاح المحدد في ذلك الوقت ، لذا فقد
بدأ هذا يبدو وكأنه خطأ  على دراية
بالنوع السابق من حملات اللقاح
خارج روسيا
ولكن للإجابة على سؤالك مباشرة
لا بالطبع لن آخذ هذا ،
ولا أعرف شيئًا عن هذا اللقاح